[Music]
joining me now is eel yakobi one of the
students who spoke on Capitol Hill today
he's a senior at upen y all great to see
you um were you satisfied with what you
heard from the University presidents
today not at all specifically when uh
congresswoman stefanic asked Liz McGill
a very direct and clear question in my
opinion does the code of conduct of the
University of Pennsylvania allow
students and professors to S to say and
rally around the idea of the genocide of
Jews it was a very direct question and
president McGill said there needs to be
context provided to calling for the
genocide of Jews I don't understand what
context she is referring to and it's
it's Terri it's terrifying for for
myself and other students the genocide
of Jews doesn't violate the code of
conduct are you serious are you
surprised by this what you've seen
lately see I'm not surprised at all
because I live this back in the 80s at
Dartmouth and it was it was obvious to
me then it's only gotten worse since
then um but as the intensity of the
anti-israel and pro Hamas sentiment on
campus surprising to
you I think there's going to be hate no
matter where anybody occupies space 100%
there there will be hate that's the
unfortunate reality of the situation
well you can't Outlaw hate but this is
something very very different than that
isn't it 100% And so when University
administrators become ambivalent to such
hate and don't hold students and faculty
accountable for perpetrating such hate
that's when it becomes a bigger issue
and something that can end up in a
student seriously getting physically
harmed and I would hope that the
universities agree with me that that
should be avoided now I know you're um
in in another student are filing a
lawsuit against upen for egregious
violations of of federal civil rights
law by selectively enforcing its rules
of conduct but I want to play something
else she said and again this is in line
with what I said in the angle about what
they're doing about all types of bigotry
on campus
watch we are in the midst of making
certain that all anti-bigotry efforts
ensure uh education about anti-Semitism
some parts of our program do and some
parts of our program need to be enhanced
so we're working on that right now and I
assure you that we will make certain
that that is included in all of our
anti-bigotry efforts
anti-Semitism anti-bigotry efforts are
underway on campus
I feel for anyone who experiences hate
no matter if they're Jewish or not I
seriously do it's a tragedy and someone
who's experienced direct hate on welcome
to the world I'm hated by a lot of
people I I just don't care but this is
something again very very different this
is calling for the the genocide of the
Jew Jews and the excusing of the
beheading of babies and what's been
happening on Penn's campus has been
festering since 3 months ago when pen
openly invited in sponsor speakers like
Roger Waters who dressed up as a Nazi SS
soldier at a Berlin Conference these
were professors inviting them and at
this point my class list has been
shortened to you know not as many
classes as I should be able to partake
in because there's professors one of
which just tweeted during the
anti-Semitism uh hearing today #gaza
Holocaust he all this is this is not
surprising to many of us who've been
documenting what's going on on campus
but I think the anti-Semitism and the
anti-americanism is like this it's gone
like this and and I am so happy that you
came to Capitol Hill as difficult as it
was and I wish you all the best uh with
what you're doing and certainly we stand
with the Jewish people thank you so much
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else